Welcome.
Well what I want to do now is
actually I'm going to use this
graphing application to explore
the trigonometric functions or
explore the graphs of them.
And just to start off or just
to let you, this application
I'm using is from gcalc.net.
it's G C A L C .net.
It's not mine, but I want to
give them credit because
that's what I'm using and
I hope they don't mind.
So let's start off just
graphing some functions.
Let's start off with
the sine function.
So let's say sine of x.
I hope you all can see it.
I'm typing it in up here.
So sine x, let me graph that.
Look at that.
Like how nice that looks.
So let's interpret this.
So it's oscillating
between-- well, let's
just go point by point.
I guess that's the
easiest way to do it.
So when x is equal to 0, what
is the value of this function?
Well, if we look here, the
value of the function is--
let me actually trace it.
When x equals 0 and it has
it written down at the
bottom of this grey area.
So when x is 0, y is also 0.
And if you're remember when we
looked for the definitions
in the unit circle
that's what we got.
That the sine of
0 radians is 0.
And now as we move on, or
move along the curve, I
have the trace function on.
This is when x is equal-- if we
look in the grey area at the
bottom left it says 1.57.
But what is that?
If you're familiar with
the-- 1.57 is more
commonly known as what?
It's 1/2 of what famous number?
Right.
It's half of pi.
We're at pi over 2.
And if you want to convert
pi over 2 to degrees
that's 90 degrees.
So when we're at the angle of
pi over 2 radians the sine
function is equal to 1.
And if you go back to some
previous modules you'll
remember that that's exactly
what the sine function was
equal to when we looked
at the unit circle.
Because we were essentially
at the point 1 comma 0.
I hope it's not confusing that
I keep referring to the unit
circle that you can't see.
But we'll keep going.
But one thing I want to
introduce here is the concept
of the period or the frequency
of the sine function.
It's pretty obvious to you at
this point that the function
keeps repeating itself.
It goes from 0, moves up to
1, goes back to 0, goes
down to negative 1.
Then goes back to 0 and
then repeats again.
So the period of this periodic
function because that's what we
call a function that keeps
repeating, the period of this
periodic function is this
distance from here to here.
And what's that?
Well, that's 2 pi radians.
And does that make sense?
Well sure, because 2 pi radians
is one complete revolution
around the unit circle.
And then it repeats again.
And then it goes the other way.
You go 2 pi radians
backwards and things
start repeating again.
Pretty interesting, right?
Oh, and another thing.
What two numbers does
it oscillate between?
It oscillates between
positive 1 and negative 1.
And that makes sense because in
the unit circle you can never
get to a point on the perimeter
of the unit circle that's
larger than positive 1 or
less than negative 1.
And that's why the sine of x
keeps oscillating between
these two points.
Let's do the cosine of x.
Actually, I'm going to
leave the sine of x there.
Interesting.
It looks almost the same,
but it looks shifted.
It actually looks shifted
to the left about
pi over 2 radians.
And that's actually the case.
So let's first think about why.
We figured out before that
sine-- actually, it looks
like this program is still
tracing the sine function.
That sine of 0 was 0.
But if you look at the green
function, the cosine of
0 radians is actually 1.
Let me see if I can-- no.
I don't know how to trace
the cosine function, so
I'll just do it here.
The cosine of 0 is 1.
And why does that make sense?
Well, the cosine is
the x-coordinate on
the unit circle.
When you have 0 radians or 0
degrees, you're at the point 1
comma 0 on the unit circle.
So 1 is the cosine or is
the x-coordinate and
0 is the sine value.
And if any of this is
confusing, review the video
where I use the unit circle to
solve the various values of the
trig functions and then
this should make sense.
And notice that this has
a period similar to
the sine function.
It starts at 1, goes down
to negative 1, and then
comes back to positive 1.
And it takes 2 pi radians
to complete that cycle.
And just like the sine function
it's oscillating between 1 and
negative 1 because on the unit
circle you can't get to a point
on the perimeter that's
higher than that.
And now to really hit
the point home let's do
the tangent function.
I think this one
might surprise you.
Well, look at that.
So the blue line is
the tangent function.
And why does it do
this crazy thing?
Well, if you remember, the
tangent function is equal to
the y over the x on the
perimeter of the unit circle.
Or since the y is the sine and
cosine is the x, it also equals
the sine over the cosine.
So here, tangent is 0
whatever sine is 0
because that makes sense.
Because tangent is equal
to sine over cosine.
So it makes sense that when
sine is 0, tangent is 0.
But then, as the sine function
becomes greater and the cosine
function becomes less, the
numerator in the tangent
function becomes greater
because the numerator is sine.
So we get larger and larger
values, all the way to the
point where the denominator of
the tangent function, which is
the cosine function-- I think
this is probably the most
confusing module I've ever
said because I can't really
write these things down.
The denominator goes to 0.
The cosine right here.
And then tan spikes and it
actually approaches infinity.
And if you look back at the
unit circle, that actually
might make a little
bit of sense.
But like the other functions,
actually the tangent
function has a period of pi
instead of pi over 2.
Instead of 2 pi.
And I'll leave that as
an exercise for you
to think about.
But with that drawn
out, I'm now going to
explore something else.
Let me reset this.
Yes, I really want to reset.
I drew the sine
function before.
Let me draw the sine
of let's say, 2x.
Whoops, that's not right.
sine of 2-- maybe I need to
put some parentheses in.
Oh, there we go.
Actually, let me reset it.
Yes, I want to reset.
So first I'll draw the
sine of x and then I'll
draw the sine of 2x.
So what's the first thing you
notice about the difference
between these two?
The brown one is sine of x and
the green one is sine of 2x.
They both oscillate between the
same two numbers and just so
you know, the height of the
oscillation is called
the amplitude of this
periodic function.
So in both cases, the amplitude
is 1 because they oscillate
from 1 to negative 1.
So the amplitude is 1, but
their period is different.
Sine of x takes 2 pi radians to
complete one circle-- one cycle
while sine of 2x only takes pi
radians to complete one cycle.
So it actually completes
it twice as fast.
And I want you to sit and think
about why sine of 2x has 1/2
the period of sine of x.
And you can probably
guess what happens if
I type in sine of 3x.
Actually, let's do sine of 4x.
It should have 1/2 the
period of sine of 2x then.
And it does, even though
this is probably a
very confusing graph.
So let's explore.
So I think you understand
what the coefficient
on the x term does.
When you have a larger
coefficient it kind of
speeds up the cycles.
And let's explore a
little bit more.
Let's start off with
sine of x again.
And now, instead of making the
coefficient larger, let's
make the coefficient less.
Let's make it sine of 0.5x.
Look at that.
Now, all of a sudden, it
takes 4 pi radians to
complete one cycle.
And I want you to think
about why that is.
Because we're now slowing
down how fast it cycles
through the angles.
Now I want to start playing
with the amplitude.
So we had sine of x, what do
you think will happen if I put
in this 2 times sine of x?
So here, the period
is the same.
It's still 2 pi, but notice
that it oscillates between 2
and negative 2 instead of
between 1 and negative 1.
So whatever the coefficient, or
whatever the number is in front
of the sine or the cosine
function, that actually
affects its amplitude.
And similarly, we can
look at 0.5 sine-- let's
say 0.5 sine of 2x.
Interesting.
So now it only goes up to
0.5 and down to minus 0.5.
So it's amplitude
is 1/2 or 0.5.
And it also oscillates twice
as fast as the sine function
because it was 0.5 sine of 2z.
I think that's all
the time I have now.
I have a feeling this might
have confused you more than
helped, but I'll still put
the video up just in case
it's helpful for someone.
But in the future I might
actually record another video
where I can actually write
things down so it doesn't
confuse you as much.
So if it confused you
I apologize, but I
hope it was helpful.
See you later.